- Welcome to MAM-217
Technical Deep Dive.
We're gonna talk about
building composable AI agents
for partner solutions with AWS Transform.
My name is Murtaza Chowdhury.
I lead product management
in the AWS Transform Team,
and I'm going to be joined
by two esteemed colleagues,
Alexis and Ravi.
And later in the presentation
we'll also have a partner join us
and show how they have worked with us
to build composable agents.
Here's the roadmap for today.
We're going to talk about the
journey with AWS Transform
and how we have started with
several point solutions
that we had at AWS.
We combined them together to provide
a centralized experience
with consistency across
the different migrations,
and then how we are extending forward
to bring partners along with us
so that there is one unified
experience for customers.
We are going to talk about
the components that enable composability,
we'll cover use cases,
we're also gonna touch upon best practices
that we recommend to our partners,
and we have several demos in this session.
And if you want to take
pictures, please feel free.
Here's where we are with AWS Transform.
We made the service generally
available in May of this year.
If you're following the
announcements that we had this week,
the current state of the service is that
we have several specialized agents
for some of the key workloads
that we have identified
based on customer feedback,
which starts with migrating
on premises data center
workloads to the cloud,
which involves mapping
the technical artifacts
on premises to what it means in the cloud.
Like identifying things
like which applications,
which workloads should
be grouped together,
the servers, the
applications, the databases,
figuring out the mapping between
the networking topologies on
premises and in the cloud,
and that's what constitutes our
migration agents for VMware.
Then we have modernization for mainframes.
There are mainframes that have been built
several decades ago,
and customers have asked
us to help them identify
what those applications do,
comprehend those solutions.
So, we have capabilities like
extracting business rules
out of legacy mainframes,
generating documents
which help them understand
what those applications do,
and taking the step forward
in terms of modernizing
them to modern languages
and migrating them to the cloud.
Then there are Microsoft
workloads, Windows.
We started with .NET workloads,
.NET framework based applications,
which are Windows bound.
And customers asked us to
provide them the ability
to make them compatible
with open source frameworks.
So, where we started is helping
with agentic experiences
to convert .NET framework based
applications to .NET core,
which can be run on Linux
based either VMs or containers.
And this week, we expanded that experience
to become full-stack.
We included SQL server modernization there
so that when you are looking at
Microsoft workloads as a whole,
you can modernize not
only the application,
but also the databases along with them.
The fourth pillar that we have here
that we announced this week is Custom,
AWS Transform Custom.
We understand that the variety
that you have in workloads
and your needs in terms of
frameworks, applications, APIs,
cannot be just handled
with specialized agents.
We want to provide you the ability
so that you can scale based on your needs.
So what we offer with AWS Transform Custom
is a set of out of the box agents
for use cases like Java upgrades,
node upgrades, or Python upgrades.
And in addition to that,
you can build your own transformations
using AWS Transform Custom
by providing input/output
samples or documentation,
and you can create them centrally,
provide them to the practitioners
in your organization,
and have them run that at scale.
In addition to that, we
revamped the entire experience.
We have a new look and feel
in the user experience.
So what I'm showing you here is a glimpse
of the web application for AWS Transform.
We also have IDE-based plugins
for use cases like .NET and Java.
So, what you see here,
let me walk you through the
information hierarchy here.
To start with, we have workspaces,
think of them as the security boundary
or a collaboration space
where your teams can work together
and you can assign different
roles to your team members
based on how your teams are structured.
There can be administrators,
there can be contributors,
there can also be read-only users.
And within these workspaces,
your practitioners can
create different job types
based on the capabilities
that we talked about earlier.
And you see there are
four workspaces here,
one for VMware, one for
Windows, one for Mainframe,
and one for Custom.
You can have them together
as well if you want to have
multiple job types in the same workspace
or keep them separate depending on
how your teams are structured.
And within workspace are jobs,
that's where you can execute
those transformations.
And how jobs work is that
it assesses what your needs are,
it assesses what your environments have
and creates a job plan for you,
and then goes and executes
those steps in the job plans.
And the job plans comprises of several
task agents that we have.
In fact, across all the specialized agents
and custom transformation
that we have here,
there are dozens of task
agents that come together
to provide you this
seamless, unified experience.
And then we have the chat experience.
The entire experience
can be led through chat,
where practitioners, you yourself,
can chat with the agents
and the chat can recommend you next steps.
Human supervision is an important aspect.
Whenever there is
something to be reviewed,
the chat agent recommends,
and takes help from you
to take the next step.
We also have artifacts here.
Think of artifacts as the commonplace
where your digital footprint
of migration modernization
are stored for your team
members to work on it together.
And you can manage collaborators
there at a workspace level.
We also have connectors.
As you are migrating and
modernizing your applications,
you will need connectors based
on where your workloads are,
either it is on premises
or they're already running on the cloud,
and the connectors both on the source side
as well as on the destination side.
So you can manage all of that
in the boundary of a workspace here.
And an important aspect
of all of this is that
there is a continuous learning loop.
As you execute your migration
and modernization jobs
in that secure workspace,
the agents learn from what
your practitioners do,
and the next steps that it recommends
is based on that learning
that enriches over time,
the more and more you use it.
We have come a long way
where when we started,
we ourselves at AWS had dozens of tools
that were specialized for specific tasks.
Like, we had a separate
tool for migration,
we had bunch of tools for modernization,
for re-architecting, for mainframes.
So when we launched AWS Transform,
we brought them all together.
And what you see in AWS
Transform now is a consolidation
where all agents and
task agents work together
to provide you that seamless experience.
And what we have now,
while we have a singular experience for
execution of migration
and modernization needs,
we have partners which
most customers leverage
and the partners have their own tools.
So, we still lack a
single governance layer
across the partner tooling and
the tooling that have at AWS,
which in many cases led to
duplication and friction.
So what we bring you here today
with AWS Transform composability
is taking a step further
to what we did with our tools,
now, taking a step further to bring
the partner tools and solutions together
to have a centralized experience
for the practitioners and the customers.
So, if you are a partner
who is a migration
or a modernization competency provider,
you can integrate your tools,
your agents, and your knowledge bases.
If you have specialized
domain-rich experiences
on specialized industries,
you can bring them together to build
a cohesive experience in AWS Transform.
How it works together is
that there is AWS tooling,
there is partner tooling,
and then there is a personalized workflow,
which is customized based on
what you want to provide your customers.
And the practitioners and
the customers no longer
have to go to multiple places.
They see one seamless experience,
one seamless job type, or
an augmented knowledge base,
that they can execute centrally
and bring down the time and
effort to modernize and migrate.
Where we have come here is
from fragmented tooling to unified agents.
Not only is this bringing
together the experience,
it is also providing
a singular governance and security layer.
And our approach to this is that
we want to co-innovate with partners.
So, if you are a partner,
you have a solution in mind,
you have a functionality in
mind, you have existing tooling,
or if you are already in a
journey of building agents,
please talk to us.
We are going to work
with you and co-innovate,
and bringing those together,
and providing a central
experience to customers.
And the benefits are both for
partners as well as customers.
So if you are a partner,
you can differentiate yourself
with your specialized IP
and your domain knowledge
and create that personalized
and customized workflow.
And for customers, it is faster
migration and modernization.
So, here is what it looks like.
From a partner standpoint,
you start by telling us
what you want to build.
You can reach out to us either
via your partner development
manager or partner SA,
or if you're a partner,
you're already familiar
with Partner Central.
We are starting an experience there
where you can lodge a request
on what you want to build
with your business case and your solution,
and how you want to
differentiate yourself.
And then we build together
and then you can publish the
agents that you build with us.
And you have the flexibility
in how you publish those agents,
either within your own account
or within your customer account,
or if you want to make
it broadly available.
We also have the ability to
integrate with AWS Marketplace
and provide a SaaS-based
delivery from there.
And from a customer standpoint,
it's as simple as plug and play.
Customers or practitioners,
partners, if you are also a GSI or an SI,
you can simply enable
those published agents
and put them to use.
I'll show you what the
customer experience looks like
once the agents are published.
So, the starting of the AWS
Transform experience is,
is configuring and enabling
it in the AWS console.
So here, we have a new experience
called partner agents,
where any new agent that
is collaboratively built
by partners will be seen
once it's published.
And from a customer standpoint,
it can simply be enabled,
and once it's enabled,
it starts showing up in the workspace.
What you see here is a set of workspaces
that you might have,
and once that agent is enabled,
it shows up as a job type.
It also depends on what the use case is.
If you want to create a new
job type, it'll show up there.
If you're augmenting a knowledge base,
it will personalize an existing job type.
Or if you have another use case,
that'll be seen here as well.
Now that you have seen at a high level
how this thing will work,
I want to invite on
stage my colleague, Ravi,
who will talk about the components of it,
which makes this possible.
Ravi.
- Thank you, Murtaza.
Before we dive into the components,
let's basically take a step back
and look at what it means for you
to integrate your tools and
agents into AWS Transform,
because that's the basic
thing that you need to do
before you can take advantage
of the composability components.
So for that, I'm gonna start small, right?
And here, I've actually built
a simple tool agent, right?
This tool agent is similar to
what tools you may have yourselves, right?
Where this tool agent is helping with
network file conversion, right?
It follows a multi-step flow
to be able to get its work done.
It helps with converting
the network files,
which are stored in S3 bucket.
It analyzes them after downloading it
and then it verifies
for the proper content,
and then goes ahead and converts them
and finally uploads it into
another location in the same S3 bucket.
You don't have to worry too much about
the network file formats
and everything like that
because that's not the focus
of what I'm going to go for.
The mechanics and the overall
experience and outcome
doesn't change whether it's a simple agent
that I'm demonstrating here
versus something that you have yourselves,
like from a tools and agent's perspective.
So, let me kickstart the agent here.
So, what I have here is a local
development environment, right?
And this is my agent,
I'm just gonna start running it.
And the agent is running
through its paces,
the tool agent,
and you can actually see what it's doing.
Let's pause here for a minute.
Once it's completed, you can actually see
all the text output in the terminal.
As you can see here,
it's very hard to follow
what the agent actually did.
There's no easy way for you to know
what are the distinct phases
that it actually went through
for you to know whether it's
performing properly or not.
So now, let's go ahead and think about
what you can do with AWS Transform.
To do that, what I've done
is taken the same tool agent,
integrated with our AWS
Transform package, right?
Which comes with base agent modules,
which allow you to easily integrate
with the AWS Transform primitives.
So here, as I continue,
you can actually see that
I'm gonna start running
the AWS Transform enabled tool agent.
You'll quickly identify that now you have
a listening capability added to the agent.
This is enabled by default
when you actually integrate
with the base agent module capability
that is provided with the AWS Transform.
And it also leverages
the AWS client's SDK,
and the other capabilities that help you
to integrate your tools and
agents into AWS Transform.
Okay, now this is on my local
development environment.
If I want to really see
how actually looks in the web application,
I'm gonna switch into the web application.
I'm firing up a browser,
and I'm going to the URL,
which basically will take me
to where the agent can actually be seen.
This is the first time
I'm running my browser,
and so this agent, the
browser, connecting to it,
so you'll actually see what's
happening is that it says,
okay, you cannot do it, right?
And you first need to go ahead
and make sure that you are
properly authenticated.
It's gonna throw me into
the username, password,
input mechanism for the identity provider
that I've been integrating here with.
Once I give the credentials,
it's happy with it,
and it's going to go ahead and redirect me
back after signing me
in, into the actual page,
which corresponds to my agent's job.
This is where it is.
So, I just want to reflect on something.
You are probably seeing
Murtaza's slides show
all the white background based theme.
You'll see here that I'm
actually showing a dark mode,
it's your preference, you
can choose whatever you want.
We now have all the capabilities
of being able to switch between
the themes quite seamlessly.
I'm a dark mode person, so I like this.
So now, let me go look at
what's in the job plan pane
that we typically talk about, right?
Oh wait, there's nothing in here.
Why is that so?
So what happened here is that
we basically kick started
the initialization process
of the agent locally,
but we have not still
given a command to it
to be able to say, start
your execution, right?
So how do you do this?
You do this by enabling the
capability that comes built in,
to be able to take
JSON-RPC or HTTP commands.
And this is all documented in the guide,
which is actually a accompanying
with the AWS Transform
integration package.
So, to avoid long command lines,
what I've done is basically
created a small script, right?
Which allows me to just go
ahead and, oh, sorry, shoot.
Okay.
Apologies for the mix up here.
Let me show you the...
Okay, I'll have to go through the demo
all from the beginning.
Sorry about that.
Okay, while it's running
through the paces,
I'll probably just go through
and explain what it's gonna do, right?
So, the first thing you do
is you initialize your agent.
The next thing you basically
do is start running your agent.
And for running your agent,
you have to use JSON-RPC
or HTTP commands, right?
Which are basically documented as part of
the package that you received
in the documentation guide.
And when you do that,
then you can go back and
see your agent executing
in the web app itself.
And here, it's actually going
back, again to the login page,
because I'm rerunning the demo for you.
But pretty soon we'll get to the point
where you'll be able to go ahead
and see the agent in action.
Okay, we are back at the
place where we started.
The job has been initialized,
but it's not been executing yet.
So I'm gonna run my script,
which basically allows me to go ahead
and kickstart the JSON-RPC
command I talked about, right?
And now I'm gonna switch back.
Now I'm gonna open back the job plan.
The job plan is a place
where you will be able to see
what is the thing that the
agent is gonna do, right?
As you can see it quickly populated it
with what it's gonna do.
This is the plan of execution
of what the agent is gonna do by itself.
So you can crisply see
what all the salient phases
it's actually going to go through
to be able to get its job done.
So now as it keeps
executing more and more,
you'll actually start seeing that it'll go
and complete one step at a time,
as you can see here,
just completed step one.
Let's look into the
artifact work logs, right?
So here, you have the work log,
which basically allows you to
see the progress of the job
as the agent is executing
it, one at a time.
And also you can refer back
to it, like, what happened,
if you are not in front of your computer.
So as the agent is running through,
well, let's keep go
back and we'll see that
it's completing multiple steps.
And again, we'll go back into the work log
and you'll see that it's
populating the work log entries.
What it's actually helped you
do is to be able to go ahead
and say that I have a
very crisp understanding
of what my agent is actually doing, right?
And if something goes wrong,
I can go back and look at what went wrong.
It was much harder for
us if you think about
the case we started with, right?
Where you have a terminal and
you have all the log messages,
all interspersed.
You could probably say,
oh, I could probably go
ahead and integrate it
with some other tool and look at it,
but it takes time and effort
to be able to do that.
With AWS Transform, you get all these
in a very easy integration package.
So, now that we've looked
at some of the capabilities,
let's go look at what all does
AWS Transform help you with.
Okay.
Security.
Security is the underpinnings
of AWS Transform.
As you have seen, no
one can easily connect
to the agent without being authenticated.
By integrating with AWS Transform,
you enable your tools and
agents to seamlessly integrate
with the enterprise identity providers.
Every action in AWS Transform
needs to be authorized.
And we all know how hard
it is to be able to deal
with credential lifecycle management,
getting the credentials, refreshing them,
renewing them at the right interval,
and also handling revocations
is a critical but painful aspect
of being able to manage connectivity.
AWS Transform's built-in capabilities
offload this pain off your development,
so that you can actually focus
more on your business logic
and not worry about all these other things
that basically are painful, right?
And you've actually seen
some of the capabilities
where you can look at what
the agent has been performing
and you can actually get audit trails.
So, Murtaza talked about AWS Transform
being built for
collaboration in mind, right?
By using the workspaces and the roles,
you can delegate job responsibility
among your team members
while approvals provide
the critical oversight
for very, very large blast
radius based actions, right?
And by integrating with AWS Transform,
you get to leverage a
secure artifact storage,
which has data encryption at
rest capabilities built in.
It also allows you to take an optional
customer managed key by
integrating with KMS,
which is AWS Key Management Service.
And your agents can help you
prevent and detect abuses
by leveraging the built-in
capabilities from AWS Transform.
We all know how painful it is to be able
to impose this on our customers,
so we don't want to do that.
And so, by integrating with AWS Transform,
you get all these four very,
very easy integration effort.
The next aspect that we want to talk about
is basically how you can actually
seamlessly see the workflow
from the agent being executed.
You saw the job plan being orchestrated
and how easy it was to follow
what the agent was doing.
The job plan management or
orchestration capabilities
of AWS Transform span the
entire life cycle of the agent.
So, it enables both single
agent based workflows
for orchestration and also
multi-agent orchestration flows.
AWS Transform helps your agent gain
human to agent interactions
by enabling the human-in-the-loop
or the HITL pattern, which
is the most common pattern
for human to agent interaction,
and also agent to agent interactions.
So, once you are ready
with building your agent,
you've tested it, all
this good stuff is done,
you want to go ahead
and deploy your agents.
So how would you deploy agent is,
normally is you probably acquire compute
and then you have to provision them
and you have to go ahead
and plan for the capacity.
AWS Transform comes with
built-in integration
with Bedrock AgentCore runtime.
This allows you to use
the on-demand capabilities
to be able to seamlessly scale
your compute requirements.
The optional autonomous
mode that you can enable
can allow your agents to run
without human intervention,
if your agents need that.
The agents can also harden
themselves against faults,
and be resilient to failures
by leveraging the check
pointing capabilities
that AWS Transform provides you.
And as you run your agents in production,
one of the things you wanna
do is to be able to monitor
how they're doing and
also respond to events.
AWS Transform's built-in
integration capabilities
help you get the appropriate
logging, the tracing,
and the metrics that you
need to be able to monitor
and put together robust dashboards,
and set up alarms so that
you can react to events.
So, thus far what we've
seen is how you can take
your existing tools and agents
and how you can integrate
into AWS Transform
and light up your capabilities
to become more enterprise friendly.
So now let's look at how you can use this
to be able to build more
complex composed workflows
to be able to achieve larger
transformation outcomes.
So, what does it actually mean
to have a composed workflow?
In the composed workflow
your tools and agents
work seamlessly with
other tools and agents,
both from AWS and from other partners,
to be able to achieve much more
complex transformation outcomes
that you cannot achieve in yourselves,
with just your tools and agents.
So that's the advantage of
having a composed workflow.
So, the topic of my
section was components,
now we are gonna dive into what
are the different components
that you can use to make this composition
much more seamless?
So, as we talked about earlier,
we have the base agent
modules that are shipped
with the AWS Transformation package,
which allow you to seamlessly integrate
with AWS Transform capabilities,
like the work log, the artifact store,
the job plan management,
and so on, so forth, that we talked about.
You can supercharge your agents
with domain specific knowledge
that is very, very, very
important for your businesses
by integrating with the built-in
knowledge base integration capability.
And we talked about
the Bedrock AgentCore runtime integration,
which allows you to deploy your agents
in a secure VPC-based environment
even with private networks.
And finally, when you are ready to be able
to have the agents
consumed by other agents
or be discoverable by other customers,
you can actually use the
agent registry mechanism
that's provided for you
through AWS Transform.
So, to get you quickly started on
the overall transformation
flow, this is how it looks like.
We started with step one,
where we were at the
dev build environment,
we used the AWS Strands
agents and the AgentCore SDK,
and using the base agent
modules to be able to
light up the core
capabilities of what it means
to integrate the AWS Transform.
We were able to test it
on a local environment,
and then once we were happy,
the next step is basically to leverage
Amazon's ECR capabilities
to build an image
which you can just go ahead and upload
into your own AWS account
and run on AgentCore runtime.
And what this allowed
you to do is to be able
to go test as if it's gonna run
in production in your customer's account
when it's deployed there.
And to be able to make sure
that you can interact with this agent,
you need to go ahead and
use the agent registry
to make it discoverable,
we talked about it earlier.
Once you're done with
this, you're good, right?
You can go ahead and use
the chat capabilities,
that Murtaza talked about earlier,
to be able to interact with agent,
or your other agents can seamlessly
discover the capabilities of your agent
and be able to do agent to
agent interactions as well.
So, in a nutshell, this
is what the overall
agent building experience looks like.
We started with the build capabilities
where with AWS Transform's
lifecycle management,
memory and the knowledge
base integration, everything,
how you can build a very integrated
and supercharged
experience for your agents.
We did some local testing,
and we tested for correctness.
The next step is automatically
to be able to go ahead
and deploy it for your customers use.
As Murtaza mentioned, again,
you can use AWS Marketplace as one of
the distribution channels
to be able to get it out
to your customers so that they can use it.
And we also touched upon
briefly on how you can operate
and monitor your agents when
they're deployed at scale.
Now that we have talked
about how you can take
your agents and integrate into AWS
and start building a composed workflow,
let's look at how you can
do more in terms of what
you can scale your development
environment experience
and also to be able to walk through
some of the use cases that you can achieve
that we've been able to
achieve with partners.
For that, let me invite Alexi on stage.
- Thank you, Ravi.
So, when we started thinking
about composability,
a few questions pop up to our mind.
Typically, can we do
better with our agent?
Can we enable more capability?
Can they actually start to
have their own kind of thinking
if we provide them with more knowledges?
Because it is true that
us, as human being,
the more knowledge we have,
the more reasoning we can do.
So that is one point that
I would like to present
to you today in the
upcoming demonstration.
Another element is
assuming we want to be able
to build more capable agent,
how can we give you the capability
to deploy your own agent
and own knowledge bases in
existing workflows in Transform
or build your own workflows
with your own agent?
The third question that we ask ourself is,
can we actually drive business
and technical transformation
simultaneously?
Because when we do a
migration, we do generally,
we generally do it for a business reason.
We are not migrating VMware
or business intelligence reports,
or mainframe, or .NET application,
just because we want to get
rid of the technical debt.
It's a reason,
but there is always an
expected business outcome.
So, we need the agent to be able
to help us assess priority, risk,
do waste planning, okay?
So we want our agent and your agent
to be able to develop those
emerging capabilities.
So, that leads us to another question,
if we consider that agent is
a group of digital people,
what makes a group smart?
So, usually when it comes to
agent, people are going to say,
"Well, they need tools,
they need knowledge bases,
they need memory."
But the reality is that if we
look at how we manage teams,
a group is smarter when people
can communicate together,
when they know how to share knowledge.
So, the use case I'm
going to present to you
is about, I would say, flexible reasoning,
it's not based on a study graph.
Agents are going to communicate
directly one to each other,
share information, and
come up with conclusion
and create new type of data
that did not exist before.
So, they're developing
emerging capability.
So, in this use case,
I'm an application manager
in the financial industry.
I'm owning a set of, I would say,
banking application,
and I'm based in Europe,
and unfortunately Europe
released a new regulation
this year, the DORA Act.
So know if you're operating in Europe,
you must prove that you're
managing your system properly
in case of failure, outage,
if a transaction goes well,
you need to be able to
notify your customers.
So when I look at that,
my first reaction as an
application owner is,
well, how can I know that
my system is built properly?
How can I do that?
And can I actually automatically detect
if my application are compliant
to that new regulation?
If not, how can I remediate that?
And I'm unfortunate,
because it happens to be
a mainframe application,
so it makes my life even more complex.
So, in this scenario, I'm
going to create a new agent,
the DORA agent here.
Oops, sorry about that.
I'm going to reuse an
existing mainframe agent,
the BRE agent,
which is extracting
business rules from code,
and I'm going to use Kiro
for both building my agentic system
and for doing the
remediation automatically.
The way it works,
the BRE is going to extract business rules
from the legacy source code.
I have created, and I show
that to you in a moment,
a knowledge base, the raw knowledge base,
which basically describe the DORA Act,
and I have created steering files for Kiro
to actually explain how to
create a proper architecture
for transaction management
or for managing customer
account, and similar examples.
So, I'll take you through
the first demonstration,
which is the building of that agent.
So, I am in Kiro, we have an MCP server
that can guide you and
automate the building
of something we call base agent,
which is basically what
Ravi introduced you to.
And in this examples,
I'm just asking to Kiro,
well, in AWS Transform,
and what is a base agent?
So, you can ask any
question from within Kiro
and you can be guided step by
step about what Transform is,
what are the capabilities
that Ravi introduced you to.
So in that case it's saying,
well, it's basically a foundation
where you have different agent
that can communicate one to each other,
they can interact,
you can deploy them to AgentCore,
and you have a registry of agent
to have a Marketplace-like experience,
and it's based on something
called base agent,
which is basically an improvement
over the vanilla Strands agent
so that those agent knows
how to communicate together
and make usage of the artifacts
or the human-in-the-loop
that Ravi presented you with.
So, from there I can interact with Kiro
and ask follow up question,
and I'm going to ask,
what is a base agent,
what can I do with a base
agent and how do they interact?
How can I equip a base agent with tools?
So, Kiro is going to
answer all those questions,
I'm going to go through a few of them.
Like, typically at the moment,
I don't know if you can see it,
but Kiro is giving more information
about what base agent are.
And basically, we have
two type of base agents,
we have orchestrator base
agent and we have subagent.
So, the orchestrator are there to be able
to do the reasoning part
at scale, basically,
while the subagent are
more task specific, okay?
And typically to declare a subagent,
all you have to do is use a
tool decorator from Strands,
register the tools into
the agent, and you're done.
Everything that Ravi explained to you is,
you don't have to worry
about it basically,
because you're iterating
from the base agent.
It is the same thing for an orchestrator.
So, in the next step I'm going to ask Kiro
to implement an orchestrator,
and I'm going to ask
Kiro basically to explain
how the messaging and
communication happens
between the various agents, right?
So Kiro is generating an
example for me at the moment,
and it generates an
orchestrator and a few subagent,
and basically it's going to
explain to me with a diagram
how the communication works over here.
So, if I do a pause for a moment here,
we see that basically I have my,
I have two tools which are
used into the orchestrator.
One is basically a tool
to contact the registry
that we spoke before,
which allows that agent to
retrieve a list of subagent
and other orchestrator,
it is allowed to talk to,
so you have control over
the visibility of agents.
And the second tool
which is going to be used
is a send message,
and basically you are allowing that agent
to talk to other agents,
and that's how you have
control over your communication
between the different agent
and their capabilities.
It is as simple as that.
So, moving on here, the
diagram explains the same thing
and how the messages are going to jump
from one agent to, or for the insured API,
and then be redirected
to another agent based on the agent name.
In order to save time,
I'm going to go to the part
where I'm actually asking,
sorry about that,
Kiro to generate the entire system for me,
if I can make it happen.
Okay.
So, I stay here for moment,
I'm sorry there's an issue.
So, I've been asking to Kiro
to take the example I provided to it,
and basically take me
through the different step
to basically package the agent,
create an ECR image,
push this ECR image
AgentCore, register the agent,
and Kiro implemented the
pipeline end-to-end for me
so I don't have to basically
know how those APIs works
and I can actually automate the making
and deploying of an agent.
The second demonstration,
it is about the creation
of the DORA agent.
So basically what I've been doing here
is I have created three
different sets of data.
One is the translation of the DORA Act
into YAML file over here,
which describe each and every act.
Their, I would, say main
functional features and capability.
It has been done
automatically using an LLM
and the DORA Act itself.
And from there I have
described the DORA act
per business domain and per feature.
Once this has been done,
we create an equivalent knowledge
base for the remediation.
So, it is a set of Kiro steering files
with a YAML font matter, same trick,
where we actually describe
the features and capability
that we want to be able to interact with
or to develop with Kiro.
And then we have a longer description
of the remediation when
we want to use Kiro for,
I would say, transforming the code
that we currently have in our application.
Okay, that agent is completely generic.
If you have different
kind of knowledge into it,
it'll be able to automate the remediation
of your application based
on the additional rules.
And now, I'm going to
use that new DORA agent
into a subset of the
existing mainframe workflow.
So, I'm selecting, as we
speak, as I speak, sorry,
the couple files that I want to
investigate in that application,
Transform is going to
extract the business rules,
it's going then to let the DORA agent
connect to the BRE agent.
They are going to have
a discussion together,
and basically the DORA agent
is going to get back to us
with a list of recommendation.
So it's doing similarity
analysis between the DORA Act,
which I put into a knowledge base,
and the extracted business
rule from the source code.
So that allows to do, I would say,
a functional similarity detection.
And here is the result that
I'm having, in this case,
where the DORA agent detected 24 rules
that are completely aligned
with transaction
management in the DORA Act,
and is recommending to
modify 20 of those, okay?
The detailed remediation are
saved into the artifact store
and can be used by Kiro,
but I'm getting a report in the chat,
which basically tells
me which DORA regulation
should be enforced in the application.
And then in the next stage
I'm getting the list of business rules
that I should actually enforce,
and I'm getting a link to
every Kiro steering file
that has been produced
automatically by the agent
to automate the transformation
of the code from within Kiro.
I'm going to,
so basically,
the use case was developed based on
the existing BRE agent from mainframe,
the code analysis agent from mainframe,
and the new DORA agent,
and then we push all of that to Kiro.
We could have included more
agent like DSMF agent to know,
I would say, like the
usage of those transaction
on the real system and
see their criticality,
and get more, I would say, recommendation,
because maybe that
transaction is highly critical
or is used only once a year,
and I have more time to do my remediation.
So, the best practices when
you're developing agent is
you need to think about
them as intelligent modules.
So you want to expose
their capability as skills
by using the tool, leg corrector,
that we've seen previously,
so that they can negotiate
how they're going to interact, basically.
When they need to share data,
you want to make sure that
the way the data is saved
in the artifact store
is known to the agent
so you can basically create a skills
where they describe the
schema of their data
so that they know to how to interact.
Or you may want do, like I just did,
put the data into a knowledge base
because then the retriever
is going to enable the agent
to directly exchange data, okay?
I'm now inviting Murtaza to introduce us
with the next use cases.
- Thank you, Alexi.
Several partners have been working with us
as design partners to
build new capabilities,
and one such capability is
BI migration to Quick Suite.
I'm going to invite Naveen on stage
to talk about Wavicle Data Solutions,
and how they have been working with us.
Naveen.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Naveen Venkatapathi,
co-founder and managing partner
at Wavicle Data Solutions.
We work with enterprises to help modernize
and build compossible data platforms,
and one of the ways we have
taken this to a new level
with Transform is that we have combined
our proprietary accelerators
and the powerful orchestration
layer AWS Transform brings.
We have combined these two
to build specialized agents
that can help our AWS
customers or other AWS partners
to be able to leverage
these specialized agents
to be able to drive the modernization
at a incredibly high velocity,
and lower labor arbitrage
to be able to drive
value to our customers
very, very quickly as well.
One of the things that
AWS Transform gives us
is the capability to not only build
these specialized agents
at a very fast paced way,
but it also helps create
a very, very flexible
customer experience on a very simple
chat-like interface as well.
I invite my colleague Anantha
to demonstrate our specialized agent
and how we have built this on
the AWS Transform platform.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
So, hello everyone.
My name is Anantha Choppalli.
I'm chief architect for AWS practice
within Wavicle Data Solutions.
And by partnering with AWS Transform team,
we have been able to take advantage
of the platform's inbuilt capabilities,
where we are now able
to bring our solution,
which has high impacting and
high value for our customers,
for quicker adoption by the customers.
In this case, a BI migration solution
that helps customers migrate from
their existing BI legacy
platforms over to Quick Suite,
and specifically the
QuickSight part of it.
There are several
advantages that we have seen
working with AWS Transform team
over the last several weeks,
where we have seen that
we can actually accelerate innovation
without the procurement delays.
What I mean by that is that we are able
to bring our solutions to
the customers very quickly,
which the customers would
be able to adopt very fast,
and without having to go through
longer procurement delays,
which could take several cycles
and requires heavy paperwork.
So, if you are a partner or a customer,
you know what I mean by those,
think about non-disclosure agreements,
master service agreements,
statements of work,
and not to mention any
change requests, and so on.
So all of those can be eliminated,
because the solution is
now easily accessible
in a self-service manner.
Another advantage that I would say
is enhanced is security posture.
While Wavicle, as a
premier consulting partner,
brings best-in-class
solution to our customers,
rooted with best practices and
well-architected framework,
there are often concerns from
customers about their data.
So, there are data concerns leaving
their network and data security
and privacy related things, not anymore.
Wavicle Solution now runs on
Bedrock AgentCore runtime,
which includes the security
poster that's offered in-built,
as well as now customers
can take advantage
of running the AgentCore runtime
100% within their environment.
So, this means there is
no need for additional
risk assessments or InfoSec reviews
because their data does
not leave their network.
So, you know what this means,
what happens to their data
stays in their environment.
And lastly, our offering is available
through the very familiar
Marketplace deployment channel,
that means customers
do not have to navigate
through newer procurement channels.
They can get the access to the offering
through Marketplace with the same channels
they're very familiar with.
And the next advantage, I would say,
is a rapid time-to-value for POCs,
where customers can take
advantage of doing quick POCs
without having to think
about the paperwork.
And this actually helps them
validate the product fit
for their use cases
before they can actually
think about full fledged migrations.
And lastly, I would say this
actually helps customers
unlock a better, faster cost-effective way
and self-service part to ROI.
What I mean by that is
customers can actually
do the entire BI platform assessment
that typically takes
several weeks to months
in few minutes to hours,
and once they have the exhaustive report,
as something that we will look at shortly,
as part of the demo,
they can actually use that information
to come up with an ROI,
which they can take
for internal approvals.
And all of this, once they're
ready, they can either,
if they have the skill sets internally,
they can use the self-service mechanism
to migrate all of their
reports and dashboards
to Amazon Quick Suite or QuickSight.
Alternatively, they can use
the Whitecloak consulting engagement
by partnering with their
existing SIs or GSIs
or even reach out to
Wavicle Data Solutions,
because we have done it several
times over, and over again.
So, with that context,
let's take a look at the demo.
And in this particular
case before I move on,
we'll be looking at the Power BI Analyzer,
where we'll be first looking
at the Power BI interface,
if you are familiar with that,
the Power BI reports in the workspaces,
and we would look at how we can use
the guided self-service
AWS Transform approach
where customers can with
help of a natural language
interact with the Transform platform
and help analyze their entire BI platform.
So with that,
like I said,
first we will look at the Power BI,
Power BI workspace.
And workspace in Power BI is very similar
to a folder in a QuickSight.
And in this case, we have
three reports in the Power BI.
So one of them, the first one,
is a low complexity dashboard,
in which case there's one filter,
there are a couple of
different types of charts,
and there are a few KPIs
and metrics that we have.
The second report is a high complex report
and the complexity is based on
how many objects are used in
creating those dashboards.
And as you can see here, we
have different types of charts
from heat map to pie
chart, and bar charts,
and there are some custom actions
that once someone clicks on it,
it actually does something specific.
And lastly, a very high
complexity report where again,
there are several
different types of charts
that customer has.
And think about this in the multitudes
of hundreds of thousands of
reports in a enterprise setup.
So migrating one or two is easy,
but when you want to do it at scale,
AWS Transform and Wavicle's
BI migration offering
would help.
In this case, the customer would navigate
to the AWS Transform,
select the right offering
for the Power BI Analyzer,
and create a job.
What this does is it actually
starts the AgentCore runtime
within the customer's environment
to set up the environment,
and then you can actually
start interacting
with the Transform platform
where you would ask it to
analyze your Power BI workspaces
and either you can actually
provide new credentials
or use connectors that's preset up
to connect to your Power BI service
and ask for all the Power BI
workspaces that are available.
Once you see all the Power BI workspaces,
you can ask it to select
a specific workspace
that you want to focus,
and then you can either analyze one
or all of the reports
within that workspace.
And as we can see, it actually
does a quick check to the S3,
because any intermediary
log files on all the data
gets stored in your S3 bucket.
And while this actually connects
and performs the activity
of analyzing your Power BI workspaces,
it would go through and
show all the details for you
for complete transparency.
And once you have all the details
and the data is uploaded to S3,
it would actually generate
a report in an Excel form,
which actually is your complete analysis
and inventory details
that is ready for use
to do any ROI or TCU analysis.
In this case, this is an example,
a report where you can see
there are several tabs,
and this particular tab shows
all the calculated fields
that were used in your reports
and the formulas that were used.
So, you can easily translate that
with the click of a button
when you're converting them
over to the QuickSight.
Next, it also shows those type of charts
that are not natively
supported in QuickSight
and automatically provides suggestion
to the native supported
QuickSight chart types.
And once those are configured,
and you're okay with it,
you can actually continue
with the migration process
of converting those dashboards.
Lastly, it shows the confidence ratio
of how much it actually
thinks it can actually
convert it automatically
versus those case scenarios
where it would require
some manual intervention
that may need to be
looked at case by case.
With that, there are,
I'll try to wrap up with two quick things.
First, with the help of AWS Transform
and Wavicle's offering,
you can unlock insights
to your business intelligence platform,
accelerate migration, and do
it faster, better, and cheaper.
Lastly, we are available
at our expo at Booth 611,
in case you have any questions
or would like to have a demo,
please feel free to reach out.
We are also available on wavicledata.com
should you have any questions.
Thank you.
With that, I would re-invite Murtaza.
- Thank you, Anantha.
You saw how Wavicle Data Solutions is
extending the migration
capabilities of AWS Transform,
and we are also working
with other partners,
here's what Accenture is doing,
For mainframe modernization,
where it typically targets
regulated industries
like financial services,
or healthcare, or telcos.
There are mainframes that were
built several decades ago,
and while migrating and
modernizing those workloads,
especially for the regulated segments,
the practitioners
typically have to consult
domain and industry experts.
So, instead of having to
talk to an expert separately
while performing migration,
what Accenture is doing with
AWS Transform composability
is that they're augmenting
the knowledge bases
that are available in AWS Transform
and making the chat even more powerful
so that the practitioners,
instead of going and talking to
domain and industry experts separately,
they can do it directly within
the AWS Transform interface
via the chat experience.
Additionally,
they're also extending the components
that are available in AWS Transform,
like business rule extraction,
and catering them to what
the industry specific
migration needs have.
Another partner who is
co-innovating with us is Capgemini.
Capgemini is another use case
for simplifying mainframe modernizations.
One of the key aspects of
mainframe modernization is that
many a times it requires understanding
of what the current applications
and workloads are doing,
extract the business rules,
and then take a forward
engineering approach
to create the application again,
re-imagining it,
keeping the business rules
and business logic intact
and creating the entire
architecture in a modernized form.
That's where Capgemini is leveraging
AWS Transform composability.
Well, these were the design partners.
We'd like to hear more.
And if you want to build
with us on AWS Transform,
you can reach out via your
partner development manager
or partner SA,
or tell us what you want to
build in Partner Central.
The link is available
via the QR code here.
Thank you so much for spending the time
and attending this session.